the reason why spirituality is important
is because it is reality we are not
human beings having a spiritual
experience we Are Spiritual Beings
having a human experience who I am and
what I am is not my body it's not even
my personality you know it's not the
trauma I suffered it's not what I've
been through that there is a little
spark of the Divine inside of me there's
hard data that shows around mental
health and well-being that that having
Serenity meaning purpose a losing of
one's self to a Transcendent self of the
Divine increases greatly the quality of
Our Lives we're a part of something much
greater and much more beautiful than
ourselves and in living in that state
can greatly enrich your life